i know this has been going around and i
want to touch on this because
people have been talking about how
trudeau is not pierre trudeau's son for
those of you that don't know pierre
trudeau was our prime minister back in
the day
somewhere around the 60s or 70s i can't
remember you know before my time
and um he was a very good prime minister
from what i can remember my parents
spoke highly of them
i think that's one of the reasons in
fact why they were interested in moving
from england to canada when i was a
small child so
you know his name had clout
now
some of you don't know this but the
trudeaus were swingers
and they had visits you know around the
world and i think uh
uh justin's mother's name is margaret if
i'm not mistaken let me just grab this
and get it lined up for the screen
and uh
share
and they made several visits down to
cuba
now i saw this in my feed the other day
this is on uh
patrick uh david's channel
it's an interview with jordan peterson
i'm gonna call you out on this jordan
peterson you didn't handle this right
i'm going to tell you what my thoughts
are on it after i feed back but um
there's a there's a moment here actually
here i got to make sure that the um
audio is going to play otherwise you
won't hear it
let me get through the ad on it
and to stream
there it is pause okay
so
stop and share
chrome tab
the title this is is justin trudeau the
son of fidel castro
so why why is this relevant right
because peterson says it's not relevant
it's in bad taste blah blah blah but
it's relevant because justin uses the
last name trudeau okay he's using the
good name of his f well who is supposed
to be his father
in politics that's why it's relevant and
that's why it should be called out let
me show you this clip here
let me know if you can't hear this
let me show you this neighbor of mine
asked me this question he's canadian he
says can you ask jordan peterson this go
to the picture with uh uh uh trudeau
what can you say about this this is your
world i don't know if this is this even
talked about all right so let's just
pause it here for the picture for a sec
one half is justin one half is fidel
castro if you don't know who fidel
castro is because you've been living
under a rock he was the guy that ran
cuba for a very very long time he's dead
now
but look at one half of his face over
here and one half of casper's face and
you cannot tell me that that's not his
father i don't know if you've seen
pierre trudeau uh pierre trudeau let me
just remove that actually i think
there's a a picture in this
that comes up to pierre was a whole
story of justin trudeau's you know
related to castro because look at that
you can't tell me that that's not
castro's bastard son years ago like is
this is this a show the other picture
where this other guy posted it so
apparently this is uh go to the picture
of a fidel the wife and the father so
this is a picture of them three that's
okay
on the right there is pierre trudeau
that's purportedly justin's father
it's not
when you look at the side by side face
you know the split down the middle
you can see
his mother
there's margaret with her hand on fidel
and if i'm not mistaken if they scroll
it down i think he's holding justin at
this time
father but then you put justin right
next to castro can you go back to the
other picture on twitter yeah that one
right there
it's really similar yeah is there any is
this even a conversation in canada has
anybody been telling because this is
written about many many different places
to the point where they tweeted about it
and said no castro is not just in true
though it's a it's a nasty it's a nasty
bit of innuendo and
i think it's it's
it's resentment fueled fundamentally
like in some sense it's a satirical joke
you know and fair enough but it's
it's not helpful
look it's not helpful
it is helpful
it is helpful it
it certainly establishes that the guy
that was elected on his name as the son
of pierre trudeau for the liberal party
is certainly not the son of pierre
he's a bastard stepson one of the things
that happens if you're a political
leader is you're exposed to criticism of
all sorts and and part of that's to stop
your power from degenerating to
something approximating a tyranny so you
kind of have to put up with it this i
would say is
i wouldn't
propagate the idea
okay um
first of all just
see see the problem with jordan and i
like his stuff and i've listened to his
12 rules for life but he gets a lot of
stuff wrong and he's too nice of a guy
right i mean you have to call some
out like i understand that he's trying
to be more mainstream but man dude like
it's speculation clearly it's not it's
speculation
on the part it's mean-spirited
it's mean because it could hurt his
feelings
i don't know
where do you go relationship to the
behavior of trudeau's mother
even if it was true then well what's
your point he's born a communist that's
your point that's a stupid point you
know or what he knows that castro is you
know what the point is jordan the point
is is that he got elected on his
father's good name
he wrote off
on his father's good name sorry his
purported father's good name
margaret cucked pierre there's no
question about that father and so now
he's tilting hard towards the left to
please him well that's
that's not helpful yeah clueless now
peter the truth in some sense set
themselves up for something like this
because trudeau played the senior played
ftse with castro in a way that was
rather unique in the western world and i
think that was
ill
that was not a good decision he was less
stringent in drawing a line between
the left and the radical communist left
that he might have been and so those
chickens have come home to roost in some
sense in terms of this assault on his
son and justin himself doesn't do a very
good job of drawing a distinction
between his views and the views of the
radical left and so all of that's
mangled around in this satirical attack
but
i don't think it's the most effective
it's got an element of real
gossipy innuendo and mean spiritedness
about it that i think overwhelms
whatever humorous
satire it might also contain so yeah i
mean they did this with obama's you know
when trump came out and said five
million dollars proof you get the idea
right
mean-spirited
just just hey man just holding up a
mirror and reflecting back the facts
that's that's all i'm doing here i'm
just showing you what's going on
you